Continue from the last section or load the level named 02 Cinematics Cam Dolly. Earlier, you animated the camera by moving it linearly from point A to point B.
If you need the camera to follow a particular path, you could theoretically create multiple keyframes along a trajectory, but that seldom translates into a smooth transition.
In the real world, you'd usually rely on a dolly or a rig rail. You have such a tool in Unreal Engine.
Let's animate a camera across the grass looking at the plaza.
Using the Add to Project icon, look inside the Cinematics section and drag Camera-Rig Rail Actor into the scene.
Reorient it towards the plaza.
The rig has a path. Select the endpoint and move it across the grass.
Holding Alt down, move it again to create an additional point on the path.
All three points can now be adjusted for locations and tangents.
You can add more points if you need to.
Now that you have the rig in place, you can create a camera actor to link to it.
Keep in mind it can be a different actor, like a car or a character. But for now, we need a camera to follow the rig.
Add a cine camera to the scene.
Name it Cam Dolly.
But before you move it to the cameras folder, link it first to the rail rig.
Zero out the camera coordinates to match the rig's position in space, but then move it up in space to a human height level.
Reorient it to look at the plaza.
At this point, you can move both the rig rail and the camera to the cameras folder.
You may need to relink the camera to the path.
If you select the rail and change its current position on rail value, you can see the camera traveling alongside it.
The Lock Orientation to Rail option enables the camera to rotate as it travels,
but this may be more suitable for a vehicle traveling along a path than a camera, as a good camera shot typically needs a focal point.
So instead, we'll set the camera to track a focal point, something to look at as it travels through space.
This is done by selecting the camera and enabling the Look At tracking feature.
By selecting an object in the scene, such as the dancing character,
and then scrubbing through the rail position, you'll see the camera focusing on one subject.
However, the dancing character may not be the best focal point as it's bouncing up and down like a bunny rabbit, and that could ultimately ruin the camera shot.
Instead, simply create a non-renderable actor to act as a focal point.
This way, you can place it in the scene exactly where you need it, and even possibly animate it for subtle focal point changes.
You are now ready to animate the camera in Sequencer, but first, a word of warning.
The rig rail itself is by default visible in the scene and will render if seen in a camera shot.
To prevent that from happening, make sure you disable the Render Render button.
This will allow you to render the scene in a single shot, and the camera will be able to see the scene in the same way.
To prevent that from happening, make sure you disable its Show Rail Visualization option.
If your Level Sequence is not open, select it in the viewport and open it.
You can minimize all the existing tracks and then add both the Camera Rig Rail actor and the Dolly Camera itself to the Sequence.
For now, we are mostly interested in the Current Position on Rail option of the Rig Rail, so add the track for that.
We already have a camera pan animation running between frame 0 and 300. We'll ensure the next animation runs between 300 and 600 or thereabout.
Go to about frame 270. This will ensure a small one-second overlap between the previous and the new camera shots.
At frame 270, create a keyframe with the rig camera at 0 or at the beginning of the rail position.
At around 630, create a keyframe at position 1 or the end of the rail position.
Scrub the animation to see the camera move along the path.
Somewhere around frame 300, maybe around frame 295, you need to switch the cameras from one cut to the next.
If you activate the Camera Cuts track, it is currently viewing the camera pan shot only.
But at frame 295, you can easily add a different shot by using the Plus button. In this case, we need a cut to the Dolly Cam.
As you scrub through the animation, you are now transitioning between the two shots.
Save your work. In the next section, you'll add the third shot, one that is created with the help of a crane.